can a man deny his duty to physically
protect his wife if a woman can deny sex
emotion at the night
well men they're not allowed to deny
that they're just not allowed the way
society is set up if you're
denying your wife
of that protection then you're not
serving your vows that's what they were
saying okay what do you think
i guess why not if women can deny sex
then why not i personally wouldn't it's
just wired into me like that's normal so
all right so let's say you got a girl
right and
the night before she said no to sex yeah
i'm feminine and you're human the next
day someone breaks into the house
watch you what you doing now for comedic
reasons
i'm gonna obviously
nah i can't even do it even to be like i
can't even lie
it's just in me what if she what if she
hadn't had sex with you in a year oh
[ __ ] then that's different i wouldn't
even be there that's the truth you got a
kid you got it you got a kid you're
still there for the kid i'm not there
for the kid i see the kids i see the kid
everybody
says
he said the stereotype but now
seriousness see the kid every weekend
we're good but now it's just wired into
us i think all the guys here can agree
like women kids siblings younger people
vulnerable people it's just normal like
it's just my natural instinct regardless
i was just moving it closer no no you're
next oh i don't actually get what you
mean so physically as in if somebody
breaks in he should protect me yeah
because in a marriage that's what you're
that's what you're
um that's the deal
you you give sex you give sex and
commitment and loyalty he gives you
protection and provisioning do you know
what i feel like if he denied those
things i know it sounds manipulative
but if he denied those things to prove a
point it sounds so manipulative that
maybe the woman will understand a bit
more where he's coming from by his need
for sex in the relationship so maybe
that might change her behavior and
they'll live happily by you getting
[Laughter]
one that i'm dating not a stranger no
yeah it's that aspect of my brother my
dad someone i'm dating yeah not a brand
name yeah and guys do we will expect sex
from our partner yes come on that's okay
why are you just understanding yeah just
making sure we're all on the same page
what about you what do you think
if women can turn down sex can when can
men turn down security
or protection yeah i want to say
i technically yes but do you understand
that all right sex is penetrative right
how many times do you really have to
beat up someone for your
life
how much say that say that so all right
so my point is uh sex is is a regular
occurrence it's just a regular healthy
relationship cool
like let's be realistic how often is
someone break like how okay so i think
the question should be how many times
does a man actually have to like
do protecting like i get it mentally and
things but actually someone's attacking
your woman or breaking in into your
house i feel like for the world to
function men have to protect us all the
time like we wouldn't be able to walk
we wouldn't be able to do anything like
like why do you think women couldn't
vote why do you think women didn't have
like why do you think women didn't fight
in wars the only reason the world is
stable today
as an example yeah okay that's that's
one example but okay who do you call you
call the police do you want a man or a
woman coming
a man feminism if if we if we broke out
into if we had if england was in war
today
i know here you guys can be equally
drafted but come on are they putting
women on the front lines are they
putting men who's getting drafted
first men men get drafted first yeah
if we're putting it on the same pedal
store sex i believe a man can do that
but obviously it's not nice because
she'll be hurt and she won't be pretty
anymore but he'll be horny and upset
yeah i think no wait but i feel like you
lot would i feel like i would burn you
guys more that you didn't protect rather
than
well the point is that we don't
appreciate that men protect us all the
time
like we can be
they protect us in a world where we
choose not to be with them
like and they built the world for women
and i think it's not just protection in
a sense that oh there's danger let me
get in the way of it but it's also like
looking for potential dangers so i'm
constantly thinking how can like if my
wife goes out i'm thinking i look at her
outfit and i'm like
okay what could potentially happen here
and i will say something if i think
something could happen or if i'm out and
about i'm just like i'm aware of dangers
because my instinct is to protect if
that makes sense so that's a constant
thing it's not just like when someone
breaks into the house who's more likely
to be helped if they're attacked in
public men are women women
so men are protecting us all the time go
ahead i think off the back of what he
said um
i feel like a woman really and truly
shouldn't have sex with a man she
doesn't feel protected by
if if if a woman's in a situation where
she where she's not giving sex maybe she
doesn't feel protected
i think i think that they do it to
manipulate man yeah i think like
i mean that's why it's really common
like the one thing i always hear is that
you know he takes out the trash so so he
can get laid
he's like working he's like in the
relationship and used sex that's
manipulation right because you probably
genuinely like you probably genuinely
desired your partners yeah but a lot of
women marry guys they're not really
attracted to because they want the
resources
or the children you probably genuinely
have desired your partners i think women
are most likely to just use their bodies
for protest anyway
so
not having sex could be a form of
protest when you see women at protest
they're usually taking their clothes off
so i think that's just something that
women do i think women know that their
bodies are their weapon
that's why women go crazy when a guy has
sexual discipline yeah like if we get
like i've seen it myself where a girl's
throwing herself at me and if i don't
react to it just get mad
yeah she would lose her mind yeah
so it's like it's like a man this arm in
your greatest weapon
do you guys think that's true i think it
depends on the kind of woman yeah no i
think it's true
i think it's true
what are you thinking
i just
that's what i'm saying if we're
generalizing i hear it but maybe like me
personally i just don't feel that i
would so when i was at university i took
a year at sexier to learn sexual
discipline here
and
i remember very specific situations
where literally girls trying to whip my
trousers down just because they're like
what do you mean like you're not like
going literally just kind of skits off
that's cringey wow
that's really crazy to me that's crazy
if you talk to mandom that's it's a
normal thing if a man turns on a girl
it's like how can you turn me down i'm
giving you sex like what who do you
think you are but then doesn't that
tell you a bit about her like if if sex
is such on a high pedal stool to her but
that's the thing i think if you if women
can't handle rejection that's what i
want to say
so it's like you're getting rejected is
like me giving you my body's like one of
my biggest offerings and you're turning
that down
i think it's because we're used to men
wanting sex so badly that when we
finally come across one that isn't moved
by it we're like what is going on here
do you know what i mean so that's why in
some cases it's used as a form of
manipulation yeah i agree with that
women do that a lot yeah
yeah and product yeah but
women don't have any other bargaining
chips other than that they don't what
other bargaining chips do women have
yeah they used to in the 1950s i mean
like i think women from the 1950s would
think were so weak today they'd be like
oh you left your man because you weren't
happy
my man had a whole family across town
and i stayed
yeah yeah yeah and and culturally i
think
like having a moroccan background myself
it's having more than one wife is i have
three grandmas